Darry did you learn anything from dr.
agus Howard was that that he really was
optimistic like I had this whole
doomsday thing like yesterday I spent
the whole day thinking this is 18 months
and I was really freaking out so I like
what he said a little better it's not
gonna go past this summer in terms of
our isolation I mean I my gut would be
you know four to eight weeks on the
isolation side and I think again once we
have that test and we can start identify
people who had the virus and could be on
the front lines we're gonna dramatically
stop the spread people they'll be the
ones who are driving ubers they'll be
the ones who are checking out at the
grocery store who are in the emergency
rooms and they're not gonna get sick
from the virus so we'll have a cohort of
workers to be able to protect anybody
else and to me that's proud powerful
with technology and with data we're
gonna make a big impact on this disease
and it's all starting to come and then
you add into that the drugs we have and
we're gonna make a you know there's a
positive change we're gonna go on
offense for the first time instead of
being on defense we've been on defense
since mid-january we're gonna start to
go on offense here and that's what
America is good at Gary puppet what did
you learn I wish I could watch baseball
or bowling or puzzle radio so I really
hope that dr. agus comes up with a cure
very very soon ask my most important
question does the corona virus live on
vinyl Beth just walked in honey what did
you did you listen to doctor I am with
the puppy is the greatest treatment ever
for worrying about coronavirus yeah by
the way my wife's gonna she's got to
come on because she's you know she's so
into animal rescue and the shelters are
asking people to to take in animals now
and you know this is the time to do it
we're all at home and what great project
of helping an animal it makes you feel
better I mean it I think it's great
therapy it's great for the country Timon
you can train a puppy or just have an
adult dog that's just sitting in a cage
sitting on your lap and getting you
through this tough time also an amazing
opportunity to foster your home
day you can really help the shelters
call your local shelter ask what they're
doing with fostering I'm sure they will
deliver the animal to you I don't see
everybody every adoption or rescue will
do that but they will 100% provide all
the necessary items for the fostering so
now is the perfect time to do it what is
going on in shelters are they
overwhelmed because of coronavirus think
upgrade is the same with all the
misinformation out there that people are
hearing all these horrible things that
you can get it transmitted through your
animal and it's just not the case oh so
people do not need to dump their animals
off at the local shelters right now and
that seems to be what's happening
unfortunately so shelters are full they
need help
fostering is the greatest thing and
we're doing it right now I have a couple
senior cats downstairs I have some
teenager teenagers I have to nursing
Mama's two pregnant mamas and I'm
exhausted list exhausted me and Howard